Speaker 1: All right, a big news,
at least for now and by tomorrow,
this may be different. The Joe Biden vaccine
so-called mandate, as it is known, is going to be
frozen frozen thanks to the decision of
a panel of Republican appointed judges.
Now what we call the vaccine mandate, which is why
I said so-called is the requirement through OSHA
that companies with more than 100 employees either
have their employees get vaccinated and prove that
they are vaccinated, or you just test them weekly
for COVID. So it's not much of a mandate, but it's
a protocol requirement. Call it whatever you want.
Remember that Fox News's protocol or requirement
or whatever is stricter than what Joe Biden has
put in place via OSHA at FOX. You have to prove
your vaccination status or test daily and wear
masks in certain situations. All right. Well, per
the Washington Post, a federal appeals court has
suspended has frozen the Biden administration's
new vaccine requirement for private companies.
The federal appeals court in New Orleans, one
of the most conservative appeals courts in
the country, is giving the Biden administration
until later today to respond to a lawsuit filed
by Republican led states and businesses. The
decision was issued by a panel of three judges,
all appointed by Republican presidents.
This is the U.S. Circuit Court, a
U.S. Court of Appeals for the Fifth Circuit. The
judges wrote that there was quote cause to believe
there are grave statutory and constitutional
issues with the mandate. They have stayed
the mandate while it is assessed further. What
started all of this was a lawsuit filed late last
week just before the weekend by some Republicans,
including Louisiana Attorney General Jeff Landry.
Now it's really important. This is a temporary
freeze on Biden's quote mandate. It is not a
ruling on the merits of the policy. They want
more time to look at it. It's important to recall
that vaccination requirements at the state level,
at local levels, by schools, by private companies,
they have almost completely held up in court
so far. The Biden requirement is different in
two ways. Number one, it's broader. And number
two, it's coming from the federal government,
so it is different. That doesn't mean it's
not going to ultimately stand. It is also not
actually a mandate, since you can test out doesn't
apply to employees who work remotely or outdoors,
doesn't apply to people who physically
work where other people don't work or
shop. And as we talked about last week, these
requirements do work to get people vaccinated.
Very much so you can argue that it should be
against the law. You can argue that it's immoral,
but it works and it works really, really
well. When we look at companies ranging from
United Airlines to the New York Police Department
to all sorts of companies, including ones where
people were claiming I will, I'm not going to do
it, I'm not going to do it. It works very well now
going back to the politics. This ruling was signed
by judges. One judge was a Reagan appointee,
just Judge Edith Jones and then Kyle. Kyle Duncan
and Kurt Engelhardt both were appointed by Donald
Trump. This was the New Orleans based 5th Circuit
Court, considered one of the most conservative
appeals courts in the country. It is likely that
other circuit courts, even given the same case,
would find differently. It is likely that
such a decision would probably not be upheld
by the Supreme Court if it ever got to that point.
Although we have a little bit of a wacky Supreme
Court right now, and you never know. White House
Chief of Staff Ron Klain was asked, What do you
think is ultimately going to happen? He says
he's confident it will be upheld. Of course he
would say that, but let's listen to his reasoning.
Speaker 3: I want to ask you before I let you go
about the court ruling yesterday on the vaccine,
on the vaccine protocols that Austin is putting.
Out sort of the soft mandate. I don't want to call
it a hard mandate because of the testing option.
There's a freeze. What does that mean for
the federal government's efforts? I mean,
do you stop preparing for January 4th
in the moment? How does this work?
Well, I think what it means for the time being
is that the the effectiveness of that vaccine
requirement is is frozen. I think we'll certainly
be well litigated, though well before January 3rd.
I'm not sure really has much practical effect in
the short run. Look, these vaccine requirements
have been litigated up and down the courts all
over the country. State requirements, for example,
one in Maine and every single court before this
one ruled that they were valid. The Supreme Court
has turned back several times already various
efforts to enjoin other vaccine requirements.
I'm quite confident that when this finally gets
fully adjudicated, not just a temporary order.
The validity of this requirement will be upheld.
It's common sense, chuck, if OSHA can tell people
to wear a hard, hard hat on the job, right? Be
careful on chemicals. It can be put in place
these simple measures to keep our workers safe.
Speaker 1: So of course, you would say that
with the Trump travel ban with with all
sorts of different things Trump did,
no matter what courts were doing, you always say,
I'm confident it will be upheld until there's
actually a decision otherwise. But I do think
Ron Klain is correct on this. That being said?
There's a reasonable question, was this
requirement through OSHA, the best way
to deal with anti-vaccine Republicans or had
is actually served to energize them further.
I'm very interested in how the French have done
it. I have a family aunt, uncle cousins in France,
and they came to me and they said, Sir,
because that's how my cousins talk to me.
They are very respectful of me. They said, You
know, here in France, we have a big anti-vaccine
problem. We have the distrust of government
people who are anti-vax, like in the U.S.
and we have the distrust of big pharma people here
in France, like in the U.S. and you've got a lot
of people here who believe homeopathy will treat
or cure or prevent COVID. You've got all of it.
And if they had done a mandate in France, it
would have been absolute pandemonium. France took
a different approach where they said, you don't
have to get a vaccine, but if you want to travel,
you want to go to a movie theater, you want to
go to a restaurant, you want to go to the great
cafes where you get the salmon tartare and these
great dishes, which I love there. If you want
to do all of that stuff, you just are going to
either need to be presenting a negative test from
I don't remember if it's twenty four, how many
hours every single time or you get vaccinated. And
the brilliance of it was it diffused the narrative
of a mandate, but it was like, this is something
really annoying. And so you had some people
from all walks of the anti-vaccine world
saying, I'm not, I'm not for the vaccine, but
I just want to do something. There's a specific
thing I want to do. It's not about just being able
to go to work. So I'm going to go and I'm going
to go and get vaccinated. I don't want to have
to test all the time. I want every time I want
to go to a restaurant or whatever the case may
be. So I'm wondering aloud, is that an approach
that could have been maybe more effective? But
then you have the question of is that something
Biden could really even do? Or does it have to
be done at the state or local level? Our system
is different than that, which which is the case in
France. So be curious to hear from you about that